When I was in my early 30s,
I was an associate
at a Wall Street law firm.
And I had been working 16-hour days
for seven years straight.
And even though,
ever since I was four years old,
I'd had this beautiful
and impossible dream
of becoming a writer,
I was also pretty ambitious
and on the verge of making partner.
Or so I thought.
Because, one day, a senior partner
named Steve Shalen
knocked on my office door.
Steve was tall and distinguished
and very decent.
And he sat down and he reached
for the squishy stress ball on my desk,
and he said that I wasn't
going to be making partner after all.
And I remember very badly
wishing that I had a stress ball too,
but Steve Shalen was using mine.
And I remember feeling sorry
that it had fallen to Steve
to be the one to tell me this news,
because he really was a good guy.
And I remember bursting into tears
right in front of him,
such a nonpartnerish thing to do.
But that very afternoon
I up and left my law firm for good.
And a few weeks after that
ended a seven-year relationship
that had always felt wrong.
And so, now I was in my early 30s,
and suddenly I had no career,
no love, no place to live.
And immediately,
I fell into a relationship
with a handsome musician
who liked to compose lyrics by day
and stand around a piano
with friends, singing, at night.
And he was the wrong guy
for various reasons,
but my feelings for him
developed into this crazy obsession,
the likes of which I have never
experienced before or since, thankfully.
No matter what I did,
I couldn't escape it.
Until one day, a friend said to me,
“You are this hooked
because he represents
something you're longing for.
What are you longing for?"
And the answer came to me
with a sudden clarity.
It was like, of course,
he was the writing life
that I had longed for
since I was four years old.
He was an emissary
from the beautiful world.
And just like that,
the obsession fell away,
and I started writing for real.
Today, I want to talk with you
about a state of mind
that's ancient and universal
and enormously powerful
and, strangely, these days overlooked.
The author C.S. Lewis
called this state of mind
"the inconsolable longing
for we know not what."
And he was mesmerized by it all his life.
As am I.
When I was 22 years old
and I was still in law school,
some friends came by my dorm room
to pick me up on the way to class.
And I had been sitting
and listening to bittersweet music,
which is something
I've been doing all my life.
(Music: "Adagio in G Minor" by Albinoni)
(Music ends)
OK, so the music is a little bit gloomy.
It's full of longing, right?
Maybe for a lost love
that never existed in the first place,
but the curious thing is,
when I hear music like this,
I don't really feel sad or not very sad.
What I actually feel
is something that's much closer to joy.
And I could never understand why this was.
But meanwhile, I noticed
that my law school classmates
were feeling very little joy.
One of them asked me
why I was listening to funeral music.
(Laughter)
And I laughed, and we went off to class.
End of story.
Except that I thought
about that comment of his
for literally the next 25 years.
Why do I find sad music so uplifting?
And what is it in our culture
that makes it feel
a fitting subject for a joke?
And why, even right this minute,
do I feel an intense desire to assure you
that I love dance music too?
I really do.
At first, these were just
interesting questions,
but as I looked
for the answers over the years,
I started to realize
that, really, they were the questions.
They were the big ones,
I just hadn't known it yet.
So here's what I found out.
Lots of people feel the way I do
about sad music,
especially sensitive types.
People play the happy songs
on their playlists
about 175 times on average,
but they play the sad songs 800 times.
And they tell researchers
that they associate sad music
with beauty and wonder and transcendence,
the so-called sublime emotions.
And you know, just think
of how many musical genres
tap into sorrow, right.
There’s Spanish flamenco
and Portuguese fado
and the Irish lament
and American country music and the blues.
And then even lullabies,
which all over the world we often use
our most heartbreaking melodies
to sing our newborns to sleep.
Why on Earth do we do that?
(Laughter)
And then it's not just music, right?
We like rainy days and tragic drama
and cherry blossoms,
which we celebrate
over equally lovely flowers
partly because they die young.
Philosophers call that
the paradox of tragedy.
Why do we sometimes welcome sorrow
when the rest of the time
we will quite naturally
do anything we can to avoid it?
There's actually a scholarly debate
raging over this question,
but I have come to believe
that really, what we are craving,
at bottom,
is that state of longing,
that joy that's laced with sorrow.
Which is often triggered
when we experience something so exquisite
that it seems to come to us
from some other world.
And this is why we give
painters and rock stars
such exalted status.
Because they're the ones
who bring us the breath of magic
from that other place.
Except it only lasts a moment,
and we really want to live there for good.
Because we know that we live
in a deeply flawed world.
And we have this stubborn conviction
that we come from a perfect
and beautiful one
that remains forever out of reach.
And maybe that sounds depressing to you,
but this state of mind,
this longing,
is actually the deep source
of all our moonshots and our loves.
It's because of longing
that we play "Moonlight Sonatas"
and build rockets to Mars.
And it's because we're all in this
same strange state of exile
that we have the capacity to empathize
with each other in the first place.
Our broken hearts,
taught an 18-century rabbi
named Nahman of Bratslav,
they connect us to each other
and to that other world
where the music comes form.
But modern culture
is telling us a really different story.
It's telling us to smile
and get over it and move on.
And of course it's true,
positivity is very powerful as well.
And it's possible to get stuck
in your longing
and to never come out.
So I do want to be really clear,
this is not an argument for depression.
And --
(Laughter)
If that's what you think
you're experiencing,
please, please do go seek help.
I'm talking about a different
state of mind that we all live in,
where the light and the dark
move together.
And I am saying that right now,
our culture is afraid of the dark.
And that all this normative sunshine
can distract you
from your rightful heritage.
In Homer's "Odyssey,"
it was homesickness,
it was the longing for home
that caused Odysseus to take
that epic journey in the first place.
The poem starts with him
weeping on a beach.
And in most every children's book
you've ever loved,
the hero is an orphan first.
Think of Harry Potter --
broken before the story even starts.
Longing is also
the beating heart, of course,
of most of the world's religions.
We long for Eden and Zion,
and we long for the Beloved,
which is the beautiful word
the Sufis have for God.
So sometime after I left
my law firm and the musician,
I met Ken, who would become my husband.
Ken is a writer, too,
and he had spent the past decade
doing UN peacekeeping negotiations
in Rwanda and Liberia and Somalia.
And he had done that work
because underneath
his very exuberant personality,
he was filled with his own longing
for another world.
He'd grown up haunted by the Holocaust.
He used to lie awake at night
when he was 10 years old
wondering would he have had the guts
to hide Anne Frank in his attic.
And it turned out
that he did have the courage,
even if his dreams of peace
never did come true.
To this day, he keeps on his desk
a photo of a pile of bones
from the Rwandan genocide.
When we met,
Ken was getting ready
to publish a book on his experiences,
and it was getting optioned for TV.
And in contrast,
I had this failed legal career
and some poems that I had written.
At the time, I was working
on a memoir in sonnet form,
because why not.
But I brought the sonnets
to our second date,
and I showed them to Ken.
And later that night,
this is the email that he sent me.
[Holy Sh*t. My favorite line:
I'm Penelope's descendant/
Heiress to a life transcendent
Keep writing. Drop Everything.
Write. Write woman, write.]
(Laughter and applause)
So Ken's exuberant faith
helped to make my longing a reality.
But those dreams of peace he had had,
you know, we're all
still waiting for those, right?
Which is the way it often goes,
the beautiful world just out of reach.
But while we're waiting,
our broken hearts
can also help to connect us.
(Music: "Adagio in G Minor" by Albinoni)
(Music ends)
In 1992,
the city of Sarajevo was under siege.
For centuries, Muslims,
Catholics and Eastern Orthodox
had lived together
in this very vibrant city.
And now, the streets were dead quiet.
Except for the crackling sounds
of the snipers' gunshots.
Until one day,
when a bombed-out bakery
filled with the strains
of Albinoni's "Adagio in G Minor,"
which is what you've just
been listening to,
thanks to the otherworldly talents
of my dear friend, Min Kym.
(Applause)
The Albinoni that day
was played by Vedran Smailović,
the lead cellist of the Sarajevo Opera,
in honor of 22 people
who had been killed the morning before,
as they lined up for bread.
Dressed in a formal white shirt
and black tails,
as if for a night at the opera,
he sat down on a white plastic chair
on a mound of rubble,
and he played his cello.
And he did that every day for 22 days
under sniper fire that never stopped him.
"You ask me am I crazy to play my cello
in the middle of a war zone,"
he said,
"Why don't you ask them
if they're crazy for shelling Sarajevo?"
A few months after that,
the BBC foreign correspondent,
Allan Little, writes
that he watched as a procession
of 40,000 people
emerged from a nearby forest.
They had been walking for 48 hours
to flee a military attack.
And among them was an old man.
He was dazed and exhausted.
And he asked Allan Little,
"Have you seen my wife,
we got separated in the forest,
I don't know whether she's made it."
And Little said to him,
"Do you mind if I ask you,
are you a Muslim or a Croat?"
And the old man's answer, he says,
shames him even now,
as he recalls it across the decades.
"I am," said the old man,
"a musician."
(Music: "Adagio in G Minor")
(Music ends)
In Hebrew, the word
for longing, leh-heesh-toh-kek,
it comes from the same word,
from the same root,
as the word for passion.
The place you suffer
is the same exact place
where you care desperately.
It's the same place that inspires you
to ease someone's pain however you can.
And it's the place that you vibrate
with the insane beauty of this world.
So, remember, there's light
and there's dark.
And when the dark times come,
and they will come,
don't be surprised,
but ask yourself:
What are you longing for?
And follow your longing
where it's telling you to go.
It's pointing you
in the direction of the sacred.
If you don't like
that word sacred, I get it,
call it the wondrous instead.
You don't, you absolutely
don't have to believe
in the deities of the ancient books
to know that spiritual longing is real,
and that humanity
is steeped in the sublime.
Once you look, you will see it
everywhere around you.
It's in the arch
of your best friend's eyebrow
when she makes a joke.
It's in the smallpox vaccines
and the Golden Gate bridges
that humans somehow managed to invent
against all odds.
It's in the surge of love
you feel for a cellist
who did a brave and miraculous thing
during a misbegotten war in 1992.
And it's right here in this room.
Follow your longing
where it’s telling you to go,
and may it carry you
straight to the beating heart
of the perfect and beautiful world.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)